هذه التطورات نستعرضها من غزه مع مراسله
الجزيره هبه عكيله واخر المواقف والوضع
الان على علامه يبدو هبه
نعم حاله من التوتر بالتاكيد تسود الاوضاع
في قطاع غزه بعد ان شهدت ساعات الصباح
ساعات الفجر سلسله من الغارات الاسرائيليه
التي استهدفت عده مواقع للمقاومه هذه
الغارات استهدفت بدايه موقعين للمقاومه
جنوب مدينه غزه ومن ثم موقع اخر في
النصيرات وسط قطاع غزه هذه الغارات ايضا
تابعها قصف من قبل مدفعيه الاحتلال في
المناطق الشرقيه الحدوديه من مناطق متفرقه
في جباليا شمال قطاع غزه وفي دير البلح
وسط قطاع غزه وايضا شرق خان يونس جنوب
قطاع غزه هذه
هذا القصف المدفعي من قبل
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه استهدف ما نطلق عليه
هنا وهي نقاط لمراقبه تحركات الجيش
الاسرائيلي في المناطق الحدوديه الشرقيه
والشماليه والجنوبيه لقطاع غزه القصف
الاسرائيلي والغارات الاسرائيليه تسببت
بخسائر كبيره واضرار كبيره في المواقع
التي تم استهدافها واعلنت المقاومه بانها
قامت باطلاق عدد من الصواريخ
الويه الناصر صلاح الدين اعلنت بانها
اطلقت في ساعات الفجر سته صواريخ مستهدفه
مستوطنه سيدرات كما اعلنت في بيان لها
حركه الجهاد الاسلامي او ذراعها العسكري
سرايا القدس بان المقاومه اطلقت هذه
الصواريخ ردا على اعتداءات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وممارساته وما قام به جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في الاقصى من
انتهاكات واعتداء على المعتكفين والمصلين
عدد من الاصابات بين المصلين والمعتكفين
وعدد كبير من الاعتقالات في صفوف
المتواجدين داخل ساحات الاقصى والتهديد
المستمر من قبل المستوطنين
بالقيام
بالسباحه ساحات الاقصى
بذبحه القرابين واستمرار استفزاز
المواطنين في قطاع غزه وخاصه ونحن في ايام
شهر رمضان حيث يتواجد اعداد كبيره من
المصلين ومن المواطنين ليس فقط سكان القدس
ولكن من جميع انحاء الضفه الغربيه ومن
داخل المحتل يتوجهون يوميا وبصفه مستمره
الى باحات المسجد الاقصى والاقامه
والاعتكاف في المسجد الاقصى في تعليقاتهم
واستنكاراتهم لما جرى في المسجد الاقصى
الليله قال رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه
حماس اسماعيل هنيه بان هذه ما جرى في وما
يجري في المسجد هو جريمه غير مسبوقه لها
تبعاتها وما بعدها وايضا حمل الجميع
المسؤوليه فلسطينيه وعربيا واسلاميا عما
يحدث في المسجد الاقصى كما قال الامين
العام لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي زياد النخاله
بان هذا الذي هذه الممارسات وهذا الاعتداء
السافر الذي قامت به قوات الاحتلال هو
تهديد جدي
لمقدساتنا
لمقدساتنا وبالتالي ايضا قال حازم قاسم
المتحدث باسم حركه حماس في بيان له قال
بان محاوله اسرائيل في شن هذه السلسله
الغارات والقصف على غزه هو محاوله فاشله
لمنع المقاومه من مسانده
القدس من مسابره اهالي القدس من مسانده
الفلسطينيين
وفي جميع مناطق فلسطين في الضفه الغربيه
في القدس وداخل الاقصى وهذا يؤكد ان
الساحه الفلسطينيه هي ساحه واحده وان
المقاومه ستبقى ترد على كل الهجمات وكل
الاعتداءات والممارسات الاسرائيليه وما
وصفت باستنكار جميع الفصائل بالجرائم
الاسرائيليه
من غزه